Let's walk through knitting a Swan Sock.
The construction of this sock is unusual,
but it's not hard if you focus
on each section one at a time.
We'll start at the leg or ribbing
and then knit the heel, sole and toe,
ending with the instep.
Because the sole and instep are knit
separately, the sock allows for a lot
of creativity with color
and stitch patterning.
For my sample,
I've changed colors for each section
to help make things more clear.
Instead of ribbing,
I just cast on with waste yarn and ravel cord
and knit a one inch hem
in the dark blue color.
After knitting the ankle in light blue,
I scrapped off half of the stitches.
We'll pick these up again later and join
them to the instep
stitches to finish the sock.
Next in dark blue is the heel flap,
the original pattern.
Suggest using a heel stitch or eye
of partridge stitch for a bit of padding
and durability. With your first sock
I highly suggest knitting
that heel flap plain for now.
Next, in light pink is the heel turn.
If you've knit a sock heel before, this
is just one half of a normal heel or toe.
Now the fun starts with knitting
the gusset. In light blue I cast
on the wings of section five.
To make this easier, I've used two small
yellow cast on rags and a row of ravel
cord. With this in place,
I can double eWrap and knit the cast on
cleanly with weights on the new stitches.
The light blue gusset section is shaped
with decreases to create those wings.
Next is the sole of the sock.
You can get creative in the center part
of the gusset and the sole section,
like this red and white version, adding
a bit of Fairisle with small floats.
But again, I suggest knitting a plain sock
first to get a feel for the overall
construction before adding
any stitch patterns.
My toe is dark blue.
Nothing fancy, just short row decreases
and increases to form the toe pocket.
To finish the knitting, I switched
to dark pink and knit the instep.
After scrapping off with orange
and using a little steam.
How is this going to become a sock?
First, the instep is joined to the ankle
with kitchener grafting joining
the orange scrapped off edges.
The cast on wings are sewn to the heel flap
and the instep, sole and gusset are
joined along the red dotted lines.
This may not be the prettiest sock ever,
but it's a good exercise for following
each one of the steps in this
unusually constructed sock.